et à l'international quelle attitude
adopter aujourd'hui les diplomaties à
l'égard des insurgés selon que le chef
de la diplomatie européenne lieux devra
leur parler aussi vite que nécessaire
car ils ont gagné la guerre les etats
unis pourraient te reconnaître un
gouvernement taliban s'il préserve les
droits fondamentaux de son peuple en
particulier des femmes l'iran et la
turquie font des gestes d'ouverture la
chine de son côté se dit prête à
entretenir des relations amicales quand
la russie prône l un dialogue national
la q2 l'afghanistan qui s'est invitée
lors des échanges bilatéraux ce matin
entre ministre russe des affaires
étrangères sergueï lavrov et son
homologue libyenne la correspondance la
correspondance à moscou dont antoine
clairon
sergueï lavrov recevait aujourd'hui son
homologue libyenne pour des pourparlers
concernant la crise en libye mais voilà
le ministre russe des affaires
étrangères ne pouvait pas ne pas évoquer
l'actualité brûlante lors de la
conférence de presse à savoir la
situation en afghanistan et à ce propos
il a appelé au dialogue le plus inclusif
possible dans le pays je veux dire que
notre position est encore plus logique
c'est à dire que quand on a l'ensemble
du pays qui a été pris par la guerre
civile de nous prononcions pour la
nécessité de passer à un dialogue
national avec l'implication de toutes
les parties en conflit
sur le plan confessionnel et aujourd'hui
c'est la même chose c'est-à-dire que
nous continuons à nous prononcer pour le
dialogue national qui permettra de
trouver une façon représentative
présenter les intérêts de la population
et la mise en place définitive d'un une
structure politique pour le ministre
russe ce dialogue national afghan doit
être appuyée encouragés de l'extérieur
par les grandes puissances que sont la
chine la russie ou encore les états unis
et à ce titre sergey lavrov propose de
reprendre les négociations de moscou un
format d'une discussion qui pendant des
années a pu permettre de maintenir un
certain niveau de dialogue entre les
différentes parties en afghanistan et ce
avec le concours la participation de
plusieurs pays de cette région du monde